new york times best-selling author
jacqueline woodson has written more than
30 books for young readers for memoir
brown girl dreaming won the national
book award each of her books places
black teenagers and children
at the center of their own story
woodson's new book is called
before the ever after look at that cover
i love that cupboard it'll mean
something
i think and i love the title too it
tells the story of zj
who struggles to understand his dad's
memory loss while trying to hold on to
the good memories
of the past woodson also won this year's
hans christian anderson award that's the
highest international honor
for children's book authors and she's
with us now congratulations to you on
that jaclyn woodson always good to see
you
so let's start with great to see you i
know i really appreciate you getting up
so let's talk about before the ever
after because it focuses on
um zj i keep wanting to say jay-z but zj
his dad is a uh was a former
professional football player
he starts noticing that his dad is
having memory loss his personalities
changing
and it's terrifying and baffling to him
at the same time
zj's about 12 13. why did you pick this
i could see where you were going once it
started i went oh i know
what's happening here why did you pick
this this particular topic
i think the first and foremost reason is
because i
wanted to tell a story about a
father-son relationship a very
deep and loving and cherished father-son
relationship and what
happens to it and also i wanted to talk
about
the damaging effects of contact sports
and
and how it's not just about losing these
kind of
anonymous bodies that it impacts real
people
and real lives real families and the
effect of mental illness in the family
too sometimes and that's often a very
difficult conversation
to have for anybody it is so
true and i think especially young people
one great thing
that books do is they give young people
this language by which they could talk
about stuff they might not have felt
safe talking about or might not have had
the vocabulary to talk about before and
so
with before the ever after i was hoping
to do some of that to give young people
the language and
the permission to begin to have these
conversations
the other thing that really touched me
was zj and his friends you call him the
fantastic four there's derry and daniel
um another name starts with the oh and
ollie and ali
and that his friends are there for him
and i think it's so unusual that you
give boys little boys the opportunity to
express their feelings the way these two
these four do number one they eat very
well peanut butter and banana sandwiches
i love those on soft bread
and then they have a thing with grilled
cheese and the cheese is streamed from
the bread as they're eating it
and they're having really deep personal
conversations
yet really bonding together i think
that's an important message to
send were you doing that you're mother
of a son were you doing that
deliberately
yeah i think one thing is a writer you
know what you're doing and you don't
know what you're doing so it's the
conscious the unconscious the
subconscious
and with the 11 12 year old boys i mean
they do have these kind of conversations
we don't always hear them
we don't always believe that boys are
actually having these conversations but
they
are and and i really wanted to put on
the page
these young boys who actually really
talk to each other and not only talk but
actively
listen to each other and um and
and support each other i think we think
of that kind of thing the active
listening the support the
having these deep conversations is
something that
older people do our older kids do but
young people start doing it
from an early age and continue to and i
really wanted to give
zj his boys his support system yeah that
was that's
they have very very sweet moments i also
i'm fascinated by you as a
writer of young young adult literature
and when we i look at the black lives
matter movement and so many of them are
young people who are out there marching
in the streets and i'm curious about
your take on that
and how you're processing that as well
because the black lives matter movement
is under fire at this time but also
is doing a lot of good it's still you
know
any any time there is
a creation of change there's going to be
backfire right people are
very afraid of change especially people
who have been
in some sort of position that is
threatened by that change
and what i am so excited about is that
it is young people getting out here
and saying you know not on my watch this
stops now
i'm not going to pass this down to my
kids you know i'm doing the work and
they're young people of all colors
they're young people of all
genders um they're young people of
all economic backgrounds and they are
getting out there and they're saying
no you adults might not have fixed this
but we are going to
and that makes me so happy it's a howard
graduate and chadwick boseman was a
howard graduate i know howard graduate i
saw that you did a post to him
what was your message to him
my message was that he is now one of the
ancestors
and and i believe that i believe that
people don't
leave us completely they they transcend
into someone different who support us i
mean i think you wouldn't be here
without our ancestors i wouldn't be here
without our ancestors
and i think about that a lot i think
about
the weight we carry and that we don't
have to think about
just the people in this life supporting
us but the ancestors and what they
brought
did it make you reflect exactly on your
own life because i thought
he was working that way with that
diagnosis for over four years and i just
look at my own life and think
how do we any of us have a right to
complain about anything
when i think about what has been going
through i can't stop thinking about it
i know and and you know just that day
alone
you know we wake up and we see that he
has moved on to the next place
and then later on we see that randall
keenan who was a phenomenal writer and
person
and huge heart had also moved on to the
next place and for me
i wanted to just go back to bed and then
the more i read about what um
chadwick had done and how he had done it
through his illness
and colon cancer is a very painful
illness
and the fact that he he had pushed
through it
to to create this enormous change in the
world i mean what
young kid doesn't think about the black
panther or jackie robinson
or thurgood marshall and see some future
self um
so i mean you know black panther not so
did you think let me get out what i mean
did you think jackie let me get up yeah
i was like there is no reason for me to
try to go back to bed i got work to do
if the ancestors could do it i can do it
too yes we all have work to do on many
different things jacqueline woodson
thank you so much for taking the time i
really appreciate it
before the ever after is on sale now
wherever you like to buy your books